[Música]
escala en París Braulio Moro
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos escala en París un programa
de radio Francia internacional en
colaboración con la televisión Franz 24
en español en el que cada semana damos
la palabra a representante del mundo de
las ciencias la cultura las artes los
deportes la política y claro está de la
sociedad civil Colombia recibirá en
julio próximo a representantes de todo
el continente latinoamericano
participantes de la primera Cumbre
fiscal de América Latina y el Caribe que
tiene como objetivo avanzar hacia una
tributación incluyente sostenible y
equitativa según sus organizadores para
hablarnos de este importante tema de su
repercusiones contamos aquí en nuestros
estudios con la presencia de Luis
Fernando Medina que es el representante
permanente de Colombia ante la
organización de cooperación y el
desarrollo económico la ocd Luis
Fernando Bienvenido a nuestros estudios
Gracias por acompañarnos Muchas gracias
Braulio es un placer y un honor estar
acá el presidente de Colombia Gustavo
Petro anunció este importante medida
esta iniciativa en enero pasado es una
medida una iniciativa que está
recibiendo mucho apoyo a nivel
internacional En qué consiste esta
propuesta de Cumbre fiscal bueno es el
es un punto en la mitad de un largo
camino o al comienzo en largo camino que
busca
generar cierta unidad de criterio Pero
además más comunidades criterio también
la capacidad técnica de compartir
análisis y perspectivas entre países de
América Latina
con vistas al proceso de generación de
un sistema tributario internacional más
consolidado que es algo en lo que se ha
venido a través de hace muchos años la
ocde ha participado en ese proceso
también entonces esta iniciativa viene
se suma a todos estos esfuerzos en los
que el gobierno colombiano ha sentido
Con razón que a pesar de los intentos de
coordinación internacional faltaba una
voz unificada América Latina faltaba que
América Latina tuviera también la
capacidad de hacerse sentir como un
actor más coherente
con visiones armonizadas como dije antes
intercambiando análisis intercambiando
experiencias y perspectivas entonces eso
a lo que faltaba que el proceso Sí en
general es un proceso multilateral que
viene desde hace mucho tiempo pero
donde los países latinoamericanos está
muy fragmentados Entonces eso debilita
en la negociaciones eso nos quita
capacidad de incidir capacidad de tener
análisis
coherentes la comisión económica para
América Latina la cepalca calificado
esta iniciativa de un hito recordemos
Luis Fernando América Latina sigue
siendo la región más desigual a nivel
mundial Así es así es Y a ver hay a
pesar de las enormes desacuerdos que
antes economistas latinoamericanos yo
creo que ese es uno de los puntos de
consenso y el otro es que es una región
con una presión fiscal muy baja
Colombia por ejemplo tiene
no estoy supresión fiscal en las cifras
no exacto no la recuerdo pero está como
un tono de 16 18%
que es muy por debajo del promedio de la
ocde y no inclusive es por debajo del de
otros países de la región como chile por
ejemplo a este propósito justamente a
inicios de su gobierno el presidente
Gustavo Petro lanzó una propuesta de
reforma fiscal ha pasado con muchísimas
dificultades Qué explica este rechazo de
sectores importantes de la población
siempre al problema de la fiscalidad
Bueno pues en todos los países subir
impuestos es muy difícil no De hecho yo
creo que antes fue mucho lo que lo que
se logró eso es durante un logro
legislativo haber haber pasado esta
reforma tributaria no olvidemos que la
administración anterior trató de pasar
otras reforma tributaria y no provocó
las revueltas no y del gobierno de
administración Petro fue capaz de pasar
una reforma tributaria más progresista
cosa que muchos de nuestros críticos
decían que no iba a ocurrir no y ya
hemos que ocurrió obviamente subir
impuestos en cualquier país es difícil
América Latina lo que es aún más difícil
Tal vez porque primero por la
configuración política del hecho de que
pues tenemos una el peso
desmedido tal vez de algunos intereses
económicos
un sistema democrático donde de todas
maneras
ese poder económico tiene muchísima
influencia no hay un contra de otros
actores como si lo pueda ver en Europa
el papel del dinero en la en los
procesos electorales al igual que en
Estados Unidos este es desmesurado
entonces hay una confluencia de factores
que hacen que sea muy difícil subir la
tributación a eso hay que sumarle pues
la dificultad de generar pactos sociales
ambiciosos grandes precisamente por la
fragmentación de de intereses y de las
bases sociales a todo eso hay que
agregar sin duda alguna los efectos de
la pandemia que se vivió en el
Continente latinoamericano entre el 2019
y el 2022 en ese momento en esos meses
la riqueza de los más ricos aumentó 35%
Mientras que el producto interno bruto
apenas lo hizo un 4% esta desproporción
cómo se refleja Cómo cómo se explica
justamente desde el punto de vista
fiscal Luis Fernando Bueno pues como
tenemos una tributación débil quiere
decir pues que todos estos aumentos en
en la desigualdad digámoslo así
pregobierno pues no se corrigen después
con con la tributación O sea
hay desacuerdo entre economistas sobre
qué tanto se debe permitir la
desigualdad pregobierno digámoslo así la
desigualdad por el producto del mercado
de factores yo yo personalmente creo que
no debe ser irrestricta no yo creo que
no está mal que aún ya en el mercado de
factores haya un ingrediente como se
dice ahora de redistribución Pero bueno
dejando eso de lado en América Latina la
redistribución por la vía fiscal es muy
débil entonces todas estos aumentos de
la desigualdad que ocurren por el juego
del mercado de factores luego no se
corrigen mientras que en Europa Pues sí
los mecanismos de corrección son un poco
más tiene más tono digámoslo así
entonces se amortiguan un poco estos
golpes no es uno de lo que ocurre en
América Latina lo decía Usted es una
región donde la captación Fi es muy baja
en promedio según la ocde siempre para
América Latina se sitúa Perdón en un
veintidós por ciento alrededor de un
veintidós por ciento dentro de los
países de la ocd esto sube al 34% casi
34%
hablamos del caso del presidente Petro
avanzó el presidente borich quiso hacer
lo mismo y ha habido bastante
reticencias de hecho se puede decir que
de cierta medida fracasó esa iniciativa
al mismo tiempo gobiernos como el de
México del presidente López Obrador
desde un principio dijeron No hay
reforma fiscal Cómo se va a lograr
avanzar Precisamente en ese Cumbre
teniendo estas perspectivas tan
diferentes
bueno ante todo no quiero creer que ya
el proceso de chile haya fracasado sobre
todo por mi estimado colega Francisco
safi que no está muy involucrado y que
no lo tenemos allá en este momento en
Santiago trabajando en esto yo yo no le
quiero dar todavía certificado de
defunción a la reforma tributaria de
chile y espero que Francisco lo saque
adelante
Sí obviamente Hay mucha o sea presente
yo creo que la plataforma que se está
proponiendo va a ayudar precisamente a
que haya más coordinaciones y más
voluntad política de los gobiernos
obtenemos a que tengan la capacidad de
fortalecer su voluntad política
precisamente para poder llegar a su
ciudadanías con proyectos poniendo decir
mire Es que esto está sintonizado con lo
que está ocurriendo en otros procesos de
la región hemos compartido análisis
hemos compartido datos
compartido experiencias miren que lo que
estamos haciendo Acá está en forma parte
de una corriente más amplia yo creo que
eso puede ayudar no Y además el hecho
tangible de acudir a la negociaciones
internacionales Para obtener más
beneficios para la región yo creo que
eso también va
precisamente a darle un poco más de
juego a los gobiernos cuando quieran
abordar este problema de la fiscalía Tan
débil entiendo que uno de los objetivos
está precisamente como usted lo decía en
un principio es la cooperación más que
la competencia O sea que no se produzca
un poco lo que se vive aquí en Europa
que ha habido coordinación se lo tenemos
países como Irlanda u otros que bajan
mucho los impuestos y que evidentemente
crea una especie de competencia desleal
este Sería más o menos uno de los
objetivos Sí ahora por supuesto hay que
respetar pues las
las estrategias de desarrollo de las
distintas economías de la región no O
sea no podemos ser ajenos al hecho de
que en la región hay algunos países que
han optado porque
como decía usted en el caso de Irlanda
en Europa en América tiene también hay
países que dicen no nuestra apuesta es
por una baja tributación o claramente
paraísos Fiscales como Panamá por
ejemplo por dar algún nombre Sí yo soy
embajador son sus palabras no las mías
Así es entonces pero pero sí obviamente
pues el proceso hoy estas cosas van a
dificultar llegar a una posición
unificada pero yo creo que en la medida
en que o sea eso todo eso puede esa
heterogeneidad puede convivir dentro de
un marco de cooperación de todas maneras
de todas maneras también yo creo que
cada vez estamos más cerca de
avanzar hacia un consenso de tributación
global No de hecho ya el acuerdo que han
venido impulsando la ocde por ejemplo ya
contempla un impuesto global del 15% no
O sea ya hay cada vez más una en un
entendimiento de que los paraísos
fiscales
tienen que que no se pueden permitir
estas estas asimetrías tan grandes no
Entonces yo creo que la iniciativa
América de Colombia para América Latina
va un poco sintonizada con ese cambio y
va a ayudar a reforzarlo Es verdad que
existe referencia a esta iniciativa del
ocd que hay que recordar tardó varios
años para poder consolidarse los famosos
beps por sus siglas en inglés que es
este proyecto sobre
erosión de la base
impositiva y trata y traslado de
beneficios una cosa medio técnica pero
que como lo mencionaba fija un tasa
mínima del 15% En qué se diferencia o
qué puede aportar la Cumbre de América
Latina a esta iniciativa de los Cómo se
van a complementar O qué es lo que puede
tener como un Plus si se puede decir
Bueno yo creo que hay varios aspectos
primero el proceso de la ocde todavía no
ha llegado a Puerto seguro
Está avanzando posiblemente yo creo que
este año vamos a ver tal vez ya un
acuerdo
como con más más claridad
luego falta la el premio de montaña de
alta categoría que es la ratificación de
cada estado que es más difícil
dificilísimo Qué es lo que está
ocurriendo allí lo que se está haciendo
es tratar de bueno reconociendo que la
revolución tecnológica de la
digitalización y la globalización ya son
irreversibles entonces lo que han hecho
es que ahora realmente las empresas por
su naturaleza son transnacionales sobre
todo las grandes empresas
transnacionales Entonces ya es muy
difícil saber Cómo grabar una empresa la
riqueza de una empresa hoy en día es
producto de
consumidores que están en Colombia
que consumen bienes
maquilados en China
transportados por por flotas
navieras de Liberia y la globalización
de la economía claramente y
especialmente con patentes que son de
algo de Estados Unidos etcétera De hecho
vengo diciendo hace rato que tenemos
cuidado que de pronto el paraíso fiscal
más grandes se nos van a convertir las
patentes Pues esta Cumbre va a tener
lugar del 27 y 28 de Julio próximo en
Cartagena de Indias en Colombia Luis
Fernando Medina el tiempo se nos va
gracias por su presencia en esta escala
en París muy amable por habernos
acompañado
a ustedes les damos una nueva cita la
próxima semana aquí en otra escala en
París
[Música]
[Aplausos]